il n'est pas question de fausses notes
quatre semaines que des centaines de
milliers de français se réunissent
chaque samedi pour protester et entonner
un refrain des plus clairs
une mobilisation qui grandit 114000 le
17 juillet 237 me le 6 août
le ministère de l'intérieur communiqué
chaque semaine avec l'apparition ce
mercredi d'une nouvelle note aux allures
d'avertissement pour les forces de
l'ordre les services des renseignements
prévoit 200 actions sur le territoire
français ce samedi avec toujours un
groupe des plus hétérogènes certaines
familles seront de sortie les
renseignements met en garde d'ailleurs
contre une mobilisation plus forte dans
le sud-est avec une population
mécontente de voir le port du masque de
nouveau obligatoire dans certains
marchés de plein air et fête foraine
les revendications dépassant parfois la
simple instauration du passé ni terre et
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions moment je suis pas anti vax
je suis contre qu'est ce qui a été fait
depuis cinq ans par ce gouvernement
solidaire avec tout ce qui se passe
entre le gilet jaune et retraite au
chômage désormais le renseignement
territoriales prévoit d'une possible
remobilisation des gilet jaune les
appels sont en effet plus nombreux sur
les réseaux sociaux la crainte est
d'apparition de radicaux surnommé ultra
jaune est alors évoqué une peur de
radicalisation du mouvement que ne
souhaite pas une partie des manifestants
j'espère que ça va bien se passer j'ai
moins annoncé un appel au calme à la
fois vis-à-vis des policiers et les
manifestants ont complice manifester le
plus tranquillement possible on est
complètement apolitique on est des
citoyens qui nous battons pour notre
liberté donc on a bien fait passer le
mot d'ordre ne veut pas de représentants
de quelque parti que ce soit ou
syndicats ils peuvent venir bien entendu
y sont les bienvenues mais à titre de
citoyen lambda des syndicats pour leur
très discret dans les cortèges seul
solidaires a répondu publiquement à
l'appel des derniers rassemblements
les citoyens français confrontés au
droit de manifester mais aussi appelé en
revanche par le gouvernement à faire
preuve de civisme nous sommes tous
responsables collectivement là où nous
sommes de cette lutte contre l'épidémie
si nous ne vivrons les contraintes
n'avions pas d'autre choix car c'était
cela ou la fermeture du pays c'était
cela ou de nouveau couvre-feu de nouveau
confinement un sentiment de frustration
qui grandit et qui pourrait bien
perdurer après la saison estivale les
renseignements français redoutent une
épineuse rentrée des classes
et beaucoup n'ont pas attendu la rentrée
sociale pour se faire entendre
illustration hier soir à paris avec une
terrasse sauvage place de la république
plusieurs dizaines de personnes
rassemblées pour un apéritif géant pour
s'opposer au passage ni terre les forces
de l'ordre sont intervenues mais sans
violence pour mettre fin à la
mobilisation en imposant aux
participants de repli les tables et
réactions de manifestants au micro de
charles boulery
le gouvernement a décidé de nous ruiner
la vie avec cette mesure nous empêcher
de vivre nous faire une vie de merde
hein je cite des responsables du
gouvernement est donc là l'idée c'est de
leur prouver que non on va avoir une
très belle vie et que de les ridiculiser
en fait on veut passer les très bons
moments rencontre plein de gens et voilà
ils vont non c'est pas qu'ils vont nous
gâcher la vie